Paul current will round out today's
plenary and Paul is University of
Michigan librarian and dean of libraries
as well as Arthur F through know
professor Harold T Shapiro collegiate
professor of public policy professor of
economics professor of information and
faculty associate in the Institute for
Social Research at the University of
Michigan and he has the wonderful title
of digital preservation a different
animal and surprising ways so all the
speakers will talk and we'll leave time
at the end of their of their 30 we're
left after the 20 or so minutes for
questions and then if we have time at
the very end of the session we'll take
some more closing questions and comments
so please join me in welcoming n hamma
yep great
both places at the same time good
morning Thank You Meg thank you Tim and
Patrick in the program committee for
inviting me to my first meeting of the
Society for the preservation of Natural
History collections you'll see that i
have my thing entirely written out i
have to do this because I'm Dyslexic I
don't normally mention that except that
you have SP NHC and pronounced yet
spinach that really appeals in a very
deep way thinking about what I was going
to say this morning and the context in
which I'm saying it was a good
opportunity for me to think again about
things that I knew or thought I knew
things that are pretty fundamental and
that we keep coming back to so I think I
should start with the obvious Meg's
already mentioned it none of the three
of us speaking here this morning in this
session has anything to do with the
profession of any of the professions in
the domain of Natural History Dominic is
the only true techy guy among us and
you'll notice that when he talks but
he's someone who I've learned over the
last few years who has an understanding
of the potential for digitized
collections in the framework of
collaborative research that far
surpasses that of many who speak about
it most and Paul I've known for a while
he's an economist but also a Provost at
University of librarian but in my mind
he's a humanist that has an
understanding of the things that we do
and brings to bear on them and economic
analysis adding insights of
extraordinary clarity that really would
have never occurred to me and in
interest of full disclosure I should
admit that I'm a lapsed classical
archaeologist perhaps because of having
initially chosen that profession what we
used to refer to as the profession of
the past I had the least onerous task
this morning a simply teen up the topics
of access and preservation of digital
resources and setting the stage for this
session and for the discussion that will
follow in the interest of that
discussion I intend to be brief this
morning
given that we were invited here despite
our diversity I understand we are
probably meant to be provocative rather
than pedagogical none of us have
anything teach any of you about anything
in Natural History Paul and Dominic may
have a different take on that but
they'll let us know when they get to the
stage they happen to be people i have
worked with or shared a stage with and
whose work I have followed closely so I
think I can safely say that we do likely
agree that this is not fundamentally
about collections in museums and
libraries nor is it fundamentally about
technology in the end it is about what
it has always been about understanding
the world that we live in and I think
it's good that we periodically remind
ourselves of that among ourselves we
frequently use shorthand and it's been
done this morning already a number of
times like digitization to describe a
scope of activity that we assume
everyone understands i was listening
this morning than I heard in also in the
question period digitization used four
or five times each time with an implicit
different scope and when I think we need
to be careful of that because it's clear
that words matter both among us but
especially when the big picture guys
here digitization and tend to think
optional inexpensive we'll do that later
that happened here at Yale a couple of
years ago when someone asked the
president of the university richard
levin in a kind of a town hall meeting
that yale that the president here hosts
twice a year where digitization fell
among the university's priorities you
could have heard a pin drop clearly
instead of standing up there bid what
what what digitization ambushed by the
digitization question while providing
online access to all of Yale's
collections is very high on his list
digitization not so much at least as he
understood it at that moment I know from
experience that we all come to access
and preservation in the management of
collections from different tangents and
so a discussion of basic principles is
often a useful way of louisville setting
the conversation
with agreed terms one way of approaching
our digital work is with the concept of
the digital content lifecycle this is
commonly shared I think into a great
extent common across knowledge domains
so I assume it will be familiar to
almost everyone here it isn't
particularly difficult to grasp I don't
have a pointer so I'll just moving from
basically from left to right around this
how a diagram like this can be useful in
planning not only getting going but also
in long-term planning in estimating
staff financial and technical resources
that will be required not just to get
started which is often all we think
about in projects but also to maintain
an environment for digital collections
management and access over time so at
the beginning moving to a digital
environment or initiation of a more
limited project what normally starts at
the over here the where this blue box
called selecting you're either selecting
a subset of specimens for a project or
selecting a prioritized subset of a
collection for general collections
documentation selecting though it takes
on a whole new meaning when the object
being selected is a born digital work
that is actually selected when it comes
into the collection I can imagine that
some of you may manage such assets for
digital works even though being born and
being digital are a little difficult to
square in the natural world as we
traditionally know it but we might come
back to that in discussion because I
think managing digital objects digital
objects themselves as if they were as if
they were specimens in a collection has
a priority different from managing
digital assets as we think of them most
of us have found ourselves probably at
one time or another in these projects
with more of one of these than the other
more describing that is more metadata or
more creating that is more creating the
assets whether those are images or other
digital assets usually we have more of
the describing simply because we've been
cataloging our collections much longer
than we've been
imaging but I've also seen many a
project finish up with a virtual shoebox
of digital images without any of the
metadata that might make them useful or
even findable wait until that project
manager retires and you will likely need
one of these in the probably in the
decade in 1995 1998 2 2008 or so art
museums and it may be similar in the
world of Natural History went through a
period in which federal funding agencies
in this country were so eager to help
with what they called digitization but
was really merely creating digital
surrogates once successfully captured
and annotated we move along this
activity flow from left to right to
managing those viable digital materials
over time to preserving all of them or
preserving some of them that rise to the
bar of long-term preservation and it's
always interesting to know how people
and set that and where they set it and
finally then to pushing them along to
discovery online or discovery locally
and reuse in reality things usually get
published before we tackle the hard
topic of preservation but still forcing
ourselves to imagine and plan this
sequence from the outset helps us be
clear I think about the scope of
activities and the resources that will
be required to make being digital in
collections management useful efficient
and sustainable so that was my task but
I began looking around and I found that
there are literally hundreds of these
digital life cycle diagrams and you
probably have one that you prefer or
even one that you've made up and use at
home there are lots to choose from each
adding the flavor of management that
corresponds often to specific goals peer
review in this one for example suggests
that maybe responding to a model for
managing assets and academic publishing
or something closely allied to that the
additional layers sometimes to the point
of the legibility and this happens I
think way too often the addition of
layers here suggests to me
perhaps an oversight or funding office
you know like the provost office or the
XYZ foundation has required ever more
explanation in iterations of funding
requests from one meeting to another and
has wound up with a cycle that
essentially isn't a cycle but
encompasses almost everything you might
be doing in your office other diagrams
revert to the basic elements of the
lifecycle and I think this is actually a
much more interesting way to go because
they add critical aspects of the digital
ecosystem that we live in that are
important but not inherently part of the
life cycle of digital assets such as
policy and governance and shared
community community resources like
standards data structures and data
exchange protocols the value of having a
structural view of managing digital
assets is confirmed even by the tweeting
set in the adoption of essentially
similar schemes for online syndication
and social media like this one even
though the graphic is meant for the
140-character attention span it is not
that much different from what we are
accustomed to I think in our
professional experience for still images
and 3d models that we manage
interestingly though in this diagram
there is no hint of preservation
probably for good reasons of which I can
think of several think oh Anthony Weiner
for example it's even more instructive I
think to go back 10 years or 15 years
and to look at early attempts to
illustrate what we have come to know as
the digital life cycle not known as that
then a diagram like this now seems
quaint if not occasionally misdirected
here on my side on your left is a
floating little circle called derived
media it's completely opaque to me what
that might be and it's standing near
something called interactive perception
it's hard to know how perception might
be otherwise but there seems to be a lot
of room for misunderstanding I think in
the diagram like this but if any of you
are
old enough to have been active in this
business 15 years ago in 20 years ago
you'll recognize that this probably is a
good reflection of the reality that we
were in at that time current
illustrations though are pretty
universally focused on these four topics
create manage distribute and archive
okay there's a point in driving that
into the ground because I think we look
at this and we think that we've somehow
captured something and i think we
probably have but with all the clarity
of understanding and experience that is
embedded here and really pretty finely
honed to these easily grasped diagrams
why i think why i wonder to myself are
we still coming up short with
preservation and access pollen dominic
in their talks that will follow may
argue that we're not but my sense is
very much that we are and by we i mean
not just collection managers not just
the museums in which those collections
exist but the research and creative
communities that we are part of and that
are our reasons for being i suspect the
natural history fields may be doing
better than art history and archaeology
which are the fields that i know best
but for those fields the crest
foundation released a report just last
week that still points unequivocally to
lack of access to reasonably good
digital resources in reasonably easy
ways and to the impermanence of digital
resources and scholarly outputs as the
key perceived barriers among
professionals in the field i saw an
early draft of that crest report the
same week that Tim sent me the email
asking if I would consider speaking here
this morning and my first thought was
and still is aren't what aren't we clear
on in the parts of this schedule that
include access and preservation
I had a different take on that sitting
in the town hall meeting where staff
member asked the president about
digitization my suspicions my suspicion
is that we use the terms access and
preservation in the same time in the
same way we sometimes use digitization
that is a shorthand for something we
think we know and understand and as
something we think we have fully agreed
concepts for what we really require
however is what president Levin required
from his questionnaire on digitization
more thought more thoughtful
formulations and periodically probably a
full rethink but all leave those topics
to Paul and dominate after a couple of
decades in this business I've come to
think there is something else going on
here also and that there are two basic
operating issues or modes of thinking
that become impediments and that without
really recognizing them and coming to
terms with them can begin to hobble and
disabled operations whoops one is
thinking is incremental it looks
different on this screen than it does
anywhere else and the second is
implementation may be problematic
thinking is incremental as Albert
Einstein stated problems that are
created by our current level of thinking
can't be solved by that same level of
thinking in implementing digital
technologies however often for the first
time if you've been around long enough
to do that or migrating to new paradigms
in our business and that's fundamentally
changing those businesses you might ask
how good thinking be other than
incremental we move from what we know to
what we don't know I remember for
example my best visual of this how long
the card catalog that that is a big
thing there's usually brown with little
trays with cards in it at the Bancroft
library at berkley stood silently
ignored as nearly everyone adopted the
AMA
public access catalog but you knew there
was somebody sit in an office in that
library someplace saying I know it's not
going to work I know it's not going to
work and we're just going to save this
card catalog sometimes not thinking
incrementally however and jumping to the
next best thing can be misguided but
just as often it is not so my takeaway
better to be willing to be risk takers
now in them and at the same time be
willing to accept the consequences than
not I've been involved with a number of
risky projects 10 well yes well one of
which really has become famous in the
art museum world as a cautionary tale
and it comes up at almost every meeting
of people who deal with computers in art
museums but also with projects that I
think have fundamentally changed the
environment other risky projects among
the latter was Yale's recent change of
policy on public domain works in its
collections moving all cataloging I mean
and being clear about this not just sort
of thinking we're going to do this but
saying in policy for the University all
cataloging and all digital surrogates
even of the very best quality into the
public domain that means no fees no
gatekeeping no forms to fill out no
loitering up just use an image in the
classroom the team effort that achieved
this involved library archival and
museum collections across campus and
Meg's office very importantly Meg's
office of digital assets and
infrastructure and I think the exercise
thinking through what it takes to
fundamentally change something that has
been taken for granted for better part
of a century the exercise of doing that
was as valuable for Yale as the outcome
itself the end result of course responds
like magic as expected to the fluid
nature of the network and will do even
more so when our data is as accessible
to machines as easily as it is to humans
one implementation of this policy is
this on the website of the Yale Center
for British art and it functions very
well for research you simply go to the
website
right you click on the little download I
don't if you can see there below the
current image that's showing brings up a
little box and says what do you want and
if you ask us we'll give you the biggest
fat file that we've got up to 500
megabytes but given the impediment of
the size of the pipe that usually runs
from one place to another we decided on
smaller sizes to start with but sizes
that are perfectly acceptable for full
page publication by contrast except for
a few followers like the National
Gallery of Art in Washington art museums
are stuck in the same incremental
thought patterns that have held them
hostage for over a century in a conflict
between mission and generally discount
able little revenue streams from
licensing images those thought patterns
become all the more pernicious in the
online world in particular as we begin
implementing web 3.0 technologies
implementation may be problematic
implementation may be problematic this
by the way is the entire quote the full
response of a US State Department
official in March when asked about the
future of training Afghan security
forces although no quite so fraught
because we're not there we're in our
basements usually managing collections
similar situations can and do occur for
us when we have somehow made the
environment toxic to the proposed
solution this is almost if you're in the
middle of it this is almost impossible
to recognize it seems as though no one
understands what you're saying maybe key
participants aren't on board to begin
with maybe the mission isn't fully
defined with clear and measurable
outcomes may be going in we didn't think
of or even realize all the issues in the
right order may be a good solution for
the collection is really an unwanted
outcome for the business or risk
management office getting into this kind
of fix is much easier to do than to undo
there's another diagram and I borrowed
this from megs office that we use it
Yale to help in addition to the digital
asset lifecycle to help people think
about the complexity of even some of the
small things that they decide to do or
changes they decide to make in managing
collections it's easy relatively easy to
pave the way for better outcomes within
technology implementation when you
consider the entire community and a
community that includes not just
technology but people and the content
and the shared policy and practice that
you need if you want can agree on data
and application standards your phone can
condemn terms with shared policies which
is very difficult but extremely
rewarding to do and be sure to include
administrators who may seem extraneous
and general counsel when appropriate
into those discussions and to engage
your community or communities and by
that I mean not just other people who
manage natural history collections but
researchers anyone you can imagine being
part of a research or creative community
that you could touch or would want to
touch I think the more persistent we all
are at cultivating Andrey cultivating
this kind of ecosystem the richer and
more sustainable the outcome is for all
of us we used to worry a lot about the
change and the pace of change with
technology I think because of agreement
about some of the things that I've
mentioned this morning that worry is
less so today and with respect to
managing data and data exchange we have
good reason to be optimistic even with
paradigm shifts we can see coming at us
with semantic web technologies we can
lay out migration paths based on the
solid foundation we've all contributed
to these are the very moments however at
which the last two habits i've mentioned
those of incremental thinking and less
than thoughtful implementation will
almost certainly hurt even more than
half
thank you
I meant to take questions if there are
any right right
nobody has born digital assets and the
born digital tape worms in their
collection
oh ok so we're just going to go from one
to another pop-up I thought Meg might
have something to say okay next is
Dominic Oldman from the British Museum I
don't know
hi my name is Dominic column of the
British Museum and as meg said I run a
project called research base which is a
semantic web project a collaborative
online research environment which we're
developing at the moment I got this
slide which has an interesting story
attached to it can actually had it in
his presentation because I gave it to
him a few weeks ago or a couple of
months ago and he's kindly taken it out
of his presentation but i was talking
someone this morning and they said it's
it's done the rounds as well so i don't
know if anybody's seen this picture
before but it is the vision of a
collaborative research with the British
Museum and the Library of Congress from
nineteen sixty-two so it's 50 years 50
at 50th anniversary of this vision and
we still haven't been able to make this
happen although you can see there if I
point to it the interesting thing is
that they're still using a pen and paper
to record all the results even though I
got all of these tech I'm do and that is
actually correct because we've never
been able to create a paperless office
so that is the correct part of that that
slide so my present I actually haven't
got an argument particularly I have a
lecturer attend King's College London at
moment and I've electrical dwelleth
mccarty he says it's not about what's
new it's about what's going on and I
think the presentation is a little bit
about what's going on in this arena so
in that she'll I'm talking about
technology allowing greater cooperation
and collaboration and blurring the
boundaries between these concepts in a
way that you can do when you are
collaborating and cooperating on an
individual basis without technology I'm
also talking about more open data that
helps us answer bigger questions so this
is the tim berners-lee call to say we
need more data we need more data to be
able to answer answer these bigger
questions and bring it all together I'm
also suggesting that many of us haven't
engaged with this at all and we need to
start engaging
to lift our heads out and see what's
going on and I'm also because of the
research base because it's a semantic
web project I'm talking about linked
data and semantic web and the potential
to allow us to pursue research agendas
more efficiently effectively and
sustainably I would say though that this
part of the presentation is a little bit
negative but it gets positive later on
and so I've got a number of problems to
get to that vision of the nineteen of
1962 we have to overcome quite are quite
a few problems on the left you can see a
slide that I've actually pinched from
yoga men of the Max Planck Institute and
he's been using this slide since 2006 he
used it the British Museum at a talk he
did and I suspect he still feels it's
true and it's extremely negative so lack
of content lack of infrastructure
uncertain feature of the web lack of
open access latin lotsa black soul but
what you don't know is behind that he
had some other notes with other other
issues about collaboration and culture
on on the web issues of commercial
interest lack of funds the creation and
maintenance of infrastructure lack of
coordination between initiatives
fragmentation of responsibility between
organisations lack of awareness of
scholars treasure-house mentality of
museums and archives and a whole host of
other legal issues so that is quite a
pessimistic view although obviously I'm
involved in a project that's trying to
put some of those things right so I can
only talk about the British Museum
you'll be able to think about what
situation is in your own organizations
but in the British Museum we have no
specific infrastructure for our
researchers our researchers beg borrow
and steal from other organizations in
order to do their projects our IT
budgets are fairly small and mostly go
on the operation and business sides of
the museum so so we don't support our
researchers very well
a lot of you will also know that we've
just had a fifteen percent cut in our
budgets which means that there are lots
of debates around the open access issue
and nervousness about going open access
although as I've said there one of the
secrets of Google success is being able
to offer these free services and and be
able to compete that is quite difficult
which means that we haven't really
created a vision of fiction free
friction-free networks and we're
competing on restriction we're competing
on restriction rather than innovation
and creativity and I think that's a real
problem for our researchers that's not
to say that we don't try and do massive
complicated projects with the
infrastructure that we've got we do and
this is a slide showing the partners in
one british museum project i'm not sure
exactly how many there are but they're
trying to collect British Museum's
trying to collect object data about
objects at an ancient Greek site in
Egypt and if you went anywhere else and
showed that picture they'd say well
that's a really complicated difficult
project spread over lots of
organizations bringing that together
bring that data together and doing
something coherent with it would be very
difficult and actually it's been run by
one person on a shoestring so you won't
be won't be surprised to know that it's
in his eighth year and still running and
I suspect you know projects that are
very similar to that so about a year ago
we actually looked at some of the museum
projects and took some statistics you
can see that they are on the face of it
again quite complicated so project team
sides a third of our projects are more
than 20 people and we don't have a team
of 20 people on some of our really big
IT projects so these are these are big
projects and spread over many
organizations project length over five
years fifty percent of these projects
are over five years and many of them go
on much
longer than that one of the reasons for
that might be because if you look at the
mode of communication statistics they're
all being run using email and telephone
very little use of the internet and as I
said before where we are using the
internet we're often using
infrastructure that's borrowed from
other people so what's happening out
there now is that because we as
institutions are not dealing with this
issue we're not producing the
infrastructure we're not investing in it
others are trying to do it for us and
these are the aggregators and they
include Google of course europeana which
is partnered up with the digital Public
Library of America and the BBC have also
put their hat in the ring as well for an
aggregation environment I can I'll read
the first one so the Google Cultural
Institute I've known if you've heard of
that set up a non-profit part of Google
building the largest digital record of
global history the largest it has to be
the largest for Google by recording and
hosting historic artifacts such as
first-person accounts photos documents
much more and I don't actually have to
read the rest because they're all doing
the same thing they're actually
competing with each other for this
content and in some cases are setting up
different interfaces and they're sitting
up different content standards but
nevertheless what the objective is is to
try to encourage a economy a creative
economy encourage us to engage with it
and perhaps usefully build some tools
that we can we can all use so waiting to
see what happens with that but this
leads to another problem another problem
is scale and quality so these are
aggregators trying to bring together
lots of cultural heritage data the
technology itself allows large scale
cooperation but actually you start
getting into data quality issues as well
so European or is one of the developed
aggregators of the suffering from this
comes back to some of our concerns about
releasing data so if we don't release
all of our data we're nervous about open
access and that's going
reflecting the aggregators and that's
sort of reflected in in the the results
that europeana has and the European a
portal itself is mostly used by general
audience very very few researchers and
scholars use Europe iana despite the the
millions and millions and millions of
pounds that have been put into it and as
still going into it so we can only hope
that the things change but there's also
issues about the cost and sustainability
sort of Europe Jana runs out of funding
after two hundred 2015 when its funding
runs out what happens to all the stuff
that we put into it what happens to all
the enriching projects or happens to
that data and and that relates to
another issue about how we preserve data
and how will these aggregate is linked
to our own institutional frameworks and
I think this is a big a big issue so
then a problem I did say that this is
pessimistic part of the presentation so
problem number three if he weren't
enough it's actually really difficult to
do projects with technology and it's
really difficult to do collaboration
projects with technology there's a quote
there from John Unsworth in the
collaborative model one works in
conjunction with others jointly
producing scholarship that cannot be
attributed to a single offer and I think
that's that will also be very difficult
for some academic departments digital
projects cannot be done by one person
their cross discipline and there they
are team work and so it's very difficult
to point to that the piece of work
you've actually done within it project
management becomes more difficult with
technology as well there's a quote from
from kings and a report that was done
for the ng mellon Foundation the
planning communication the essential
factors in making a collaborative
project a success technology makes
project management skills even more
premium and you can see there in the
next quote that a lot of digital
humanities projects come across
technical issues which push their their
time scales back I suspect that that's
something that they've all had
experience about IT projects sort of
slipping and slipping and slipping and
then when they slip the pressure of
delivery takes over and they start being
stopped being collaborative
so the pressure of delivery the pressure
of meeting your budget the pressure of
meeting your timescale means that
effectively you're squeezing out the
collaboration in order to get the
project done so formal collaboration
projects can can can end up not being
collaborative at all and can end up in
lots of fights and that's the last quote
from this ateres so some organizations
have tried to do something about this
and there are centers of digital
humanities now that I've trying to sort
out some of the project management
issues that put in frameworks that
putting cross-disciplinary teams they
have the people you know in the
technology they have the humanities
people they have the project managers
but even these centers collaboration is
limited centers are overlapping agendas
and activities particularly in training
digitization of collections and metadata
development redundant activities across
senses or inefficient use of scarce
resources available to the humanities
community this was the conclusion of
Diane's auric in a survey in 2008
effectively their inward looking and
they're not dealing with some of the big
data issues and this leads to the next
problem of criticism of the digital
humanities and this is a an article that
came out quite recently in the times
higher education the Internet has
revolutionized humanities research but
has the development ever more
sophisticated online resources freed up
scholars to explore new ideas or made
themselves slaves to the digital machine
and I think others will be asking
similar similar questions so that
concludes the pessimistic part of the
presentation I've got some positive news
as well scholarly tools lots of projects
to produce some really good scholarly
tools this one you might not be able to
make out but it's the bottom bit here is
a tool that is a plug-in to Firefox it's
called sottero it's a bibliographic tool
citations it allows you to put in notes
and tags it automatically takes
bibliographic information from web pages
allows you to a mature
web pages and extremely useful them and
there is a british museum project that
uses this one tool is the core
infrastructure for their collaboration
with other organizations so actually
using it as the core project database
unfortunately i don't know whether
museums are still necessary because
there's a pay wall there and i couldn't
get past that so i've only got a record
of the web page if anybody's actually
read that that i'd be interested in
knowing what the conclusion conclusion
was some other really positive
initiatives as well this is one for the
digital classicists this is someone was
talking about wikis this morning and
this is a stream lee good wiki it's
decentralized so there's none of the
formal formalities that you have in in
some of the formal projects I'm talking
I was talking about not owned by any
institution no core funding no formal
executive open to everyone regardless of
the skills expose it's not closed off to
just the scholarly experts and it is
highly successful and the number of
projects have been spawned from this
environment it sustained by the
motivation and commitment and love of
the subject of people actually use it
and an example actually and and there
are some issues about the skull of the
aspect of it and this is a quote from
Simon Mahoney's one of those digital
classes use help set up this wiki he
says the open nature the wiki is one of
the great strengths of the worky but
also one of the greatest obstacles to
its scholarly use and someone this
morning was talking about scholarly
citation but actually the benefits of
open access at way arguments regarding
its ability to act as a sizable resource
and what its main what its main benefit
is is to bring people together and
actually helped spawn new projects
projects that people are actually
interested in doing and so therefore it
has a very valuable place in the digital
classicists world and one of the
projects that actually spawned from that
group is something called plug eous it's
bringing together datasets which
describe the ancient world
hm places annotations on geographical
places in the ancient world and I just
wanted to highlight this because it
brings me into the subject of link data
and the Semantic Web so what this
instead of aggregating data this project
is simply a lining data from different
data sets and these little circles up
here represent data sets of with
different sizes of database and the
purpose isn't to aggregate them all into
a central repository it's designed to
actually align some of these data sets
that they so they can build applications
on top of them so the data itself is
still being maintained by the
institution but it's simply published in
such a way that it looks like to the
rest of the world a single a single
database and you can see here that you
can put in a place and it'll tell you
where the resources are that you can go
to look at the data about it but more
than that because it's using linked data
you can actually produce some really
interesting applications this is the
link data that they're using and all it
is is an adherence to some publishing
standards so up here you have some
ontology this is friend of a friend
which is describing some ontology about
relationships between data this is geo
it's an ontology about geographical
locations you can see that it has some
vocab area around canta tude and
latitude scores is a terminology
ontology and its use down here to give
some archaic modern names to to label
the the resource and it's all based
around this permanent URI this is a day
to URI doesn't refer to a particular
page although if you put it into a
browser it will give you a human
readable form of it refers to a thing a
thing about Athens a date piece of data
about Athens and by aligning everybody
so if everybody publishes using these
ontologies and brings them together you
can start putting together applications
that treat all of that data is if it's
coming from one single database and this
is what link data is all about
this is one of the applications that has
been produced as a result of that linked
data this is a plug-in that anybody can
use you don't have to be a partner in
the project you can plug this into your
own website you create a link for a
place name in your website and when
people hover over it this appears and it
tells you the resources about around
that they're taking place that you're
linked to and different resources come
up depending on what you want the
linking to and anybody can put this into
their into their website so coming there
then to the research based project the
research based project which is funded
by the andrew mellon foundation very
grateful for their support it's about
bringing all of those elements that I've
just been talking to you about in one
environment so the tools like sottero in
conjunction with the the wiki that we
saw from the digital classicists in
conjunction with harmonizing data with
linked data as they're doing the plug is
project it's about bringing those all
into one environment so they all those
things talk to each other so the data is
available in the collaboration
environment and tools are available to
to analyze the data and they all work
over each other and that's essentially
what what the research put the space
project is all about and it's using
linked data as the harmonizing data
process and underlying it and also it's
interested in institutionalizing the
data so again it's not interested in
aggregating these big central
repositories and silos and competing
with other people it's about importing
to do a project so if you've got a
particular project will provide the
tools to map to an ontology that we're
using on research base quickly and
easily the project's themselves can are
just additional projects but using that
technology in that online environment
enriching that data adding to it and
will do i'll show you a few screens that
are related to that and then when it's
finished and it's published being able
to allowing institutions to pull that
data out again
and bring it back into their
institutions if they want to but also
making it available to the the wider
public who can produce their own
applications if they want to as well so
serving both institutions and the
general audience he wanted to make
something out of this data and in order
to do this we need to use more
complicated ontology so the ontology is
that I was talking about with Pelagius
don't really fit into something like
research base where we're wanting to ask
more complex questions and we're wanting
to bring together data such that we can
infer new knowledge from it so the idea
about research basis that if you bring
big data sets together and you do it in
sufficient granularity snippets of
information within different data sets
can come together and infer new
knowledge and this is what again
research base is about it's about data
modeling it's about using reasoning and
influence and semantic web technologies
to unearth information that you would
never have been able to get in the data
silos that you've got at the moment this
is this is available if you want to look
at it I just wanted to give you an idea
of the granularity that we are actually
mapping this data to in terms of the sea
doc CRM ontology see doc CRM is is a
ontology that's appropriate for cultural
heritage sector but if you look at it in
detail it's simply snippets are the same
sorts of things that you saw when you
were looking at the plague listing data
page when you look at some of these
relationships that are embedded in that
diagram you can see them here you can
see how detail they are so we're going
down to the level these are the
relationships that link pieces of data
together and these are the things that
give us the granularity and allow us to
infer information from different data
sets
and of course that's quite complicated
and one of the issues with that is once
we've done it once we've mapped all of
this data once you've got it into a very
detailed data set of detailed ontology
how do you then put it out to the users
and how do you put it in a form that
users can use and understand and make it
easy to search for the data that they
want to get get hold of so once we've
done that mapping and once we've brought
dated together with then producing some
user based tools some non technical
tools that people can use and this is an
illustration of the search screen that
will be used in research base it's being
developed at the moment you can see here
that we're creating a search sentence
we're bringing together information on
art history data set but here what we've
done is aggregated some of those really
complicated relationships into some
simple relationships that people can
understand so we've we've gone through
the process of putting the granularity
in and then we've aggregated those
relationships into common terms that
people can use to explore the data and
you can keep on changing these
relationships and getting out new
results and this becomes a very good
exploring tool for exploring different
data sets it doesn't need to be art
history you can combine art history with
other disciplines and you can use
subjects within pictures to link out
with other object heights as well but
these are the sorts of tools that we
want to give to to end users to get rid
of the complexity that we've put in to
put the infrastructure in the first
place but then we want people to be able
to use use the technology in a very
simple and well thought out way and this
is another screen from from research
base so this is an annotation
application and down here we've got the
fields that are related to a particular
object and we can put in new annotations
against either the fields or the
relationships on the fields or the
object records itself so we're allowing
people to say right this is an
institutional records it's from the
Arkady you can put in if you disagree
with the data in it you can put a new
version of data and it's recorded
against the institutional URI
so it's completely linked to the
institutional record but you as a
scholar can put a new version of data
and you can put a comment in to say why
you think that institutional data is
wrong you can also put in an annotation
that links together fields on different
records and you can also put in just
general comments and what is what its
then meant to do is combine into a more
of a collaborative conversation so this
is the bottom half of that screen so
those annotations are going into it into
a widget here and actually you're
allowed to reply to them so you can
start a conversation around one of the
annotations and if you want you can
promote one of these annotations into a
full discussion forum or full research
question so you've gone from a level of
the object commenting on the object and
putting notes on the object but if
something really interesting comes out
you can promote it to a top level
research question and start exploring
another avenue of your research project
and this is again it's exactly the same
idea but with images research baseball
producing other tools as well but we're
moment concentrating on annotation tools
but you can see here that you're allowed
to start putting regions around elements
of an image and again same annotation
style applies you can annotate those
images and people can then start
replying an art and having a
conversation about those annotations or
creating their annotations themselves so
where is this this type of technology
going to be used we hope it will be used
over a large number of different object
types but also in different sectors as
well so there's no reason why a lot of
this technology can be used in the
Natural History world and the tools
produced two specific natural history
projects and I just wanted to go over a
project which is being considered the
moment it's a project between the
Natural History Museum the british
museum and the british library called
reconstructing Sloan and it sort of
based on on a concept that
is around the Enlightenment gallery that
already exists in the British Museum so
enlightenment gallery at the British
Museum is a highly collaborative
permanent fixture at the Museum it
consists of objects that come from
different museums of science museum
natural history museum the British
Library and what it does is it organizes
objects according to the way that
they've classified in the 18th century
by the 18th century collectors and I was
talking to the curator of that gallery
and it was saying that there was no way
that they could do a search on our
collection management systems to bring
back results that reflected what was in
this gallery because we're sitting
natural and artificial objects together
so if you wanted to find out what was in
this gallery have to go to the back to
the provenance information and see who
gave us the objects in order to bring it
back together this is a very manual task
of putting this gallery together and
that the links between the objects are
about development over time they're
about development over periods and over
cultures they're not classified in the
same way that would classify things in
the modern world and this is exactly
where semantic technology can can really
help because semantic technology can
bridge relationships between different
object types between different themes
turn different subjects and cultures and
bring those objects together so although
we can't do a digital search to bring
together the Enlightenment gallery on
our screens semantic data may actually
be available to help us do that in the
future and this is just just to
reinforce the fact that we were
attempting this and I think I'm
suggesting that semantic technology is
probably the way to go forward in order
to achieve a project like this but I
want to go back to the original slides
as well but it's not all about
technology it's about people as well and
we need to be bring people along when
we're introducing this technology thank
learning em questions
thank you
you
hi
so the general things that my colleagues
have said I completely agree with in
fact I have a wonderful moment coming up
where I'm going to show you a slide that
is identical to a slide that Ken showed
you and we're but for a second wonderful
moment we won't spend pretty much time
on it I'm supposed to talk about digital
preservation and I'll use that phrase
and I'll even talk about something
called sustainable digital preservation
I have to say that when people talk
about digital preservation when I
imagine is putting one's fingers into a
cast or something and then mummifying
fingers and then you've got preserved
digits but but obviously that's not
exactly what I'm supposed to talk about
which is goods I don't know anything
about it meg said I should talk about
what's involved in preserving digital or
digitized things I know a little bit
about that whether what I have to say
makes sense in the context of Natural
History collections is for you to tell
me I don't know much about Natural
History collections except that i'm a
natural history museum junkie I was
raised by my grandmother at the American
Museum of Natural History we
occasionally also spent some time in her
house but mostly we went to the american
museum of natural history because it was
more entertaining and i actually
discovered there that i was i didn't
know this was going to happen to me this
was you know 60-some years ago i was a
metadata junkie so there'd be this great
stuff and I'd be reading the little
plaque on the side you know I took that
was I was I was interested where did it
come from what was it called and then I
of course it even since I've been going
to the American Museum of Natural
History for 60 years I've gotten to see
changes in what things were called right
the Latin names of things change do you
realize you guys do that do you have any
idea how horrible that is for somebody
who's out there believing that there's
some stability to science thanks a lot
the other my other experience of Natural
History Museum's is
I've been a university administrator in
various contexts various times and on
the very first day that I was a member
of the executive committee of the
College of literature science and the
arts at the university of michigan
somebody came in with a binder about
this thick and said now we're going to
talk about the herbarium I didn't know I
have to confess what herbarium was and
the notion that we had such a thing and
it was as rich and powerful a research a
tool for research and that there was a
field called systematics that was named
that way differently than all the other
things that I thought of as being
systematic in my life was wonderful and
exciting news so I actually went and
hung out at the herbarium a little bit
discovered a little bit of what they did
and it was fun but enough of now we've
now exhausted my natural history
knowledge so I'm going to start with the
proposition that we are interested in
digitization and digitized versions of
things in in two or three or four
dimensions because things happen over
time or if we want to do string theory
on these collections more I'm not quite
sure how that would work and what I want
it I think some of the things I'm going
to say that I've learned from the world
of libraries and publishing about
digital preservation will will indeed
carry over in useful ways will see that
the the digital is different that's
going to be themed number one will keep
coming back to it may be the only theme
and we depend on digital information for
lots of things and we we don't even
bother to notice but now we have to that
access to information tomorrow here we
are in the four dimensions requires
preservation today and and of course i
really say of course i'm saying
something that ken said very clearly
mostly this is a technical manager
policy regulatory social and economic
problem the technical part is actually I
won't say it's the easy part but but but
you can imagine how it would be solved
as long as you don't go around changing
the Latin names of things and but the
the policy regulatory social and
economic parts are the more difficult
ones so we keep asking ourselves what
should be preserved who's responsible
who pays for it and for the supporting
infrastructure and cyber infrastructure
so that things can be used interoperable
in the way that Dominic talked about I
mean that's the exciting stuff right it
really changes the way you can do
science it changes the way you can do
humanities and and that's what we want
as well as the notion that was proposed
in the in the earlier earlier session
that we can increase access to things
without damaging the objects which is
also extremely cool and those of us in
the book world like that idea to my
press a button to something happened yes
it does so Alexander roof inn was a
president of the University of Michigan
and also ran various museums there I
think those that statement has to be
true at least in some form you could say
the same thing about about libraries
instead of museums there that'll work
you can say the same thing about
universities that'd work so you know I
mean you could even say I don't know
families well at least mine but most
maybe not maybe they did some other
things too there are lots of lots of
good entities right that are interested
in these these sets of problems not
museums alone but there's a really
important sense for for museums plastic
books to I think which is that the
knowledge that we're trying to increase
and then diffuse out there into the
world is stored in some way in the
objects and in their associated metadata
so there's a lot of news in a specimen
and the card next to it that says where
it came from and the chemical analysis
that's been done on it and so on and so
forth the object has
is the object is stores knowledge that
we care about we have to preserve the
thing in order to make that happen there
is an infinite literature now they're
probably not infinite a really really
really big finite literature on how to
preserve things that you all know about
that I don't there's a really really
really big finite literature on how to
preserve books and and and basically the
notion is that handle with care and
don't over use keep in a climate where
it doesn't rot too quickly is a lot of
what it comes down to and you often have
to prepare the object in order to be to
be preserved well and there's something
we sometimes forget which is that
preservation always requires a
continuing flow of resources to take
care of the thing if I just let it sit
there and there is an unheated space
right without good climate control where
anybody who wants to can walk by and do
something eventually the things actually
going to disappear on you we sometimes
forget that especially in the library
world about books because some past
Provost already kindly built the damn
building that we're keeping the books in
and so we don't think it cost anything
to keep the books there anymore some
people i don't know if the same thing
happens to the herbarium but actually if
i look at the herbarium in michigan and
how the director of it at the time
thought about it he really didn't care
about the space costs as such that gut i
was in some other budget right and in
fact those costs those costs of keeping
things are our range from not trivial to
huge for almost anything that you might
care about but the second things we have
to preserve the thing why do we preserve
it well we'd love to preserve things
because we're museum and library people
but almost everybody else preserves
things because they want to have access
to it they want to be able to use it
they want to be able to pull that
knowledge out of the thing and that's
really what you know if you can't sell
the access part
you're very unlikely to get resources
for the for the preservation so you have
to have the thing in order to make use
of it that sounds like it's obvious but
that's actually the first place that
we're going to find where digital is
really different so so how is digital
different well there are physical
differences that matter books actually
don't mind being read too much but they
do mind being read too much you read a
book enough times it goes bad on you and
time is also a not very good for books
if they were printed on acid paper which
a great many of them were we often have
lots of copies of books which is a
helper museum stuff it seems to me does
it love being handled mostly electronic
resources love being handled they love
being used it makes them feel good and
it makes it possible rust to tell
whether or not whether they are the
thing that they say that they are
because if you don't check frequently
check some just check bits right all
that stuff they turn out to become
something else and they turn out to be
in a format you can't read and all sorts
of other stuff happens to them if you
use them all the time you can actually
keep track of what they are that's
actually a really big difference there's
a second really big difference which is
which is very clear in the world of
books it was impossible it is impossible
for a library that is made up of print
collections to provide access without
also providing preservation right a
patron comes to the library and says I'd
like to read this book if the patron is
a distinguished professor of modern of
zoology you damn well better have it if
you're the University Librarian you
actually have to have have it right the
book itself which stores the information
that you care about that the professor
of zoology wants wants to have there's
no way in the print world to provide ax
without having continuously preserved
the object that you're providing access
to everybody's saying well yeah that's
obvious but wait in the digital world
it's trivial in fact it's ubiquitous
that we provide access to things that we
have absolutely no model business or
otherwise to preserve so you go to the
library's website and you pull up an
article from a journal that the library
has subscribed to on your behalf and
it's not there why isn't it there it's
actually not the library's fault library
signed a contract with the publisher
publisher said this journal is going to
be there here's the money here's the
journal ah the lot the journals website
went down yeah maybe it comes back up
again maybe it doesn't but journal was
sold to a different aggregator of
journals who decided that this journal
wasn't very interesting anymore and
nobody paid attention to the back files
this happens it happens frequently and
there's nothing in the system that
prevents it from happening the way it
was with books so the books carried
around they're carried around their
information you had to preserve them in
order to be able to deliver now you
write a contract with somebody who and
you don't own the turtle you don't own
lots of e-books you lease them under
various rules and the long-term
preservation of those things in the
digital world may or may not be taken
care of by a set of institutions
probably not relevant to sort of
original specimens and copies but once
you get into the business of using the
powerful digital tools to start doing
research on on files that describe well
that are good simulacra of the originals
and you get used to being able to to go
someplace to find something and some and
there's some entity that is that is
pulling these together aggregating them
in an interesting way and one tuesday
morning they are not there right that is
going to be a problem i think that can
face your world as well as mine so
preservation and access get unlinked in
the
in the digital world we're going the
wrong way let's let's make progress so
here's a different version this is a 9th
century clay container excavated in Peru
it's been scanned in three dimensions
right and we actually have a printer
that will print it in three dimensions
way for our cool right so this actually
allows us to preserve right and also to
provide access to the thing in a way
that we never have before my own
paranoid fears along for things like
this is somebody some Board of Trustees
some private museum somebody is going to
copyright the files they of course the
object can't be copyrighted it's 1200
years old but but they're going to
copyright the files and and or or maybe
they won't copyright the files but
there'll be a whole set of rights issues
around being able to use the digitized
versions of three-dimensional objects
that that could make it difficulty is
them when we would prefer I think to to
make it easy and then we have this the
access version here the library is
actually not sitting on that iphone but
the library catalog is and it won't be
very long before the parts of the
library that can be legitimately made
available to a user actually will be
available through an object
approximately the size of that iphone
which is an amazing business and we can
clearly get to three-dimensional
pictures and it won't be too long before
you'll be able to take something like
that iphone and hook it up to the Handy
3d printer which is down the hall or it
kinkos or in the museum and print out
your your objects so that's that's
that's as I said kind of cool the
problem again is the digital versions
can fall apart can be lost can change
format can suffer from all of these
kinds of problems
you know the physical things obviously
can suffer from versions of those
problems too but you actually have a
pretty good idea that if you put the
dead bird in a drawer and you pull the
drawer out again that that's still there
still dead still the same bird okay
whoops wrong direction you've seen this
slide before so you know and what Ken
said about it is exactly right there is
a million of these out there and they
are all approximately the same and and
often what people do use this kind of
picture for is to put costs on all of
the pieces but of course how each part
of it is done if we think about this
life cycle of digital preservation
affects the cost of the other pieces if
things are prepared well it's cheaper to
do things down the road of things are
prepared well it's more expensive to do
things now and of course we don't really
know with any kind of certainty which
things we're going to want to have taken
good care of 50 years from now the
answer let's take good care of it all is
the kind of thing that makes Provost's
fall over and also they won't give you
the money for it even if you don't
follow Barry and and then there's bit
rot but anyhow there's this kind of
picture and then this is another version
of the same story and this is useful you
just go through you make long lists of
all the things you have to do in order
to preserve something and then you ask
yourself how do you bring the resources
to it that will will allow that to
happen this slide comes from a group at
the University of California creations
curation Center in the California
digital library and they're worrying a
lot about what kinds of resource streams
of payments are necessary in order to
support a model like this all of these
lists are slightly different they're all
fundamentally similar our estimates of
what the costs are are invariably
terrible because all we can do is
estimate what the costs are with today's
technology and the way in which we use
today's technology and mostly we get
better at that so the costs ought to go
down but then we dream up new higher
levels of functionality than we've ever
dreamed up before and so the cost go
up and so it's who knows the question
what will it cost to keep a digital copy
of for the next hundred years is a
question I can answer at the level of I
have in my I have a technology that will
get that job done for you it'll cost X
what will it actually costs who knows
that also is hard on provost so I was on
a task force that studied some of these
problems and I actually looked at the
report before giving putting this talk
together it's pretty good and rather
than go into any kind of detail on it
i'm just going to commend it to you I
think it's pretty good there's lots of
relevant information for thinking about
the problems of sustainability and
problems of digitization and I'm just
going to pull a few of the highlights
out of the report and also a few of the
highlights that come from having been a
professional economist for 40 years and
you gotta admit it's wonderful that
somebody who's been a professional
economist for 40 years views his life as
being one of highlights right this is a
the optimism of the academic so there
there in a nutshell is sustainability
and not so the waterfall on the left is
behaving well and basically replenishes
you know you can predict although
everything will be different every time
it'll be about the same if all of the
stuff that's happening upstream is about
the same which of course it may not be
and the second case which is a broken
Dam you know that level of that flow is
not sustainable but if what you're
interested in is a lot of water in a
hurry it's a great thing and and we
often build stuff that looks like they
broken Dam and then wonder how we're
going to bring resources to it in order
to hold on to it over the over the long
run here I'm going to violate principles
of university fundraising and say the
what we think of as the gold standard
for sustainability in terms of bringing
sources two things is to endow them
right they get an endowment and the
endowment throws off enough money
approximately forever it's a little
tricky right now with the interest rate
being zero and all but we don't think
that the interest rates going to stay 0
and it pays it's enough to keep the
stuff you've got pay the staff and then
have a budget for cool interesting new
projects every year I claim that as a
general matter that's too much money to
give to the enterprise whatever the
enterprise might be that in fact we
should be interested in in there being
markers of ongoing demand for what the
thing might be if you endow something
today it may really be that you're stuck
with having that thing 50 years from now
when it's not of much interest to
anybody and it turns out you you endowed
the one at Yale and pretty much if there
is one in doubt someplace Yale's a good
candidate to have it and they and I
wanted Harvard and they endowed one even
they wouldn't have been doubted at
Michigan that's just not what we do they
endowed one at Stanford and I wanted
Princeton and they hand out four of them
at Oxford but only the only three of
them are actually known to the people at
Oxford and and the and it turns out that
in the digital world in the world where
you can move things around quickly in
the world where you can do 3d printing
in the world that we're talking about
now you don't need that many of them to
do those things if you had instead put
some more room made people sing a little
bit more for their supper not much
because I really do think we should have
ways to hold onto things for a long time
before we decide to abandon them you
actually might get a much more efficient
allocation of resources over time than
then pure pure endowment so I like the
idea of raising a lot of money for
something that's important and having it
you know be good enough to keep the
thing running for a decade or two and
then there's some buildings and things
and then you keep bringing new resources
to it by the way that's the way all of
our systems basically run it's not as if
things are that well endowed there's you
know there's there's annual fundraising
there's projects there's grants there's
tuition in the universe
world etc and that strikes me as a
better way to do it so this is all from
the report and starts talking a little
bit about the the organizational issues
and is not in my view fascinating about
the bottom one mechanisms to assure an
ongoing efficient allocation of
resources to digital preservation
activities that's the piece that is
actually essential and those mechanisms
crucially include what i would call
handoffs so you've got something you
think it's valuable the ownership
structure is changing for some reason
right that something was sitting not
necessarily in a public entity or the
public entity of a sitting in goes broke
right how do you make sure that we make
it important the social decision whether
or not to keep it without throwing it
away and that is a problem that in the
digital world can present itself and get
resolved and resolved unhappily like
that in the physical world it takes a
little more time because it takes time
for things to disappear on you and I
think this is this is this is another
way in which digital is different this
is just a you know if I if I had the
perfect slide here I'd show it to you
but I don't so and there we go so we we
these are these again come out of the
report there I think essentially
self-explanatory and I'm keeping you
away from lunch and I'm really deeply
hoping that someone will ask a question
so I want to get to the end of the talk
to find out if I can make that happen
the big one here is the difficulty of
separating preservation costs from other
costs the misalignment of incentives
between who owns something and who's
going to care about it 50 years from now
that's actually familiar to all of us
and is very consequential again in the
digital world because it's so easy to
have things disappear on you both okay
that's boring too I'm going to find an
interesting slide here if it kills me Oh
concluding thoughts that must be
exciting
preservation decisions are always made
under conditions of uncertainty we don't
know what the technology is going to be
we don't know what the policy
environment is going to be right
copyright law is going to change patent
law is going to change that will matter
their their social interests move around
we don't know so the key thing it seems
to me is to not do things that are
irreversible until you have to write
again this notion of handoffs I think is
really very important if you can't
preserve it can you have time to find
someone who might want to if it's at
risk for not being preserved because
it's held by some someplace that isn't
the kind of institution that cares about
preservation per se do you get to to see
it to have an opportunity to bid on it
if you will again before it disappears
and then here is a big problem that
commitments even so the commitments we
make can't be except in this pure
endowment model which is too pricey
commitments for all time so again what
we're interested in is is his
flexibility and amend my favorite recent
quote that i ran across which explains
covers most of the issues that i've been
talking about today and actually most of
the issues that i face as a university
librarian so and here i want to go back
to a theme that both Ken and Dominic
talked about if we're going to organize
ourselves the good to which we are
organized are organizing ourselves here
is the good of making things open
interoperable easily usable
approximately forever because actually
if they're open and interoperable and
easily usable there will be lots of
copies around there they'll get they'll
get used they'll get taken out and
exercised in the formats of the day the
many of the risks that I've been talking
about today won't happen thank you
questions see it says questions right
there
oh well
i won all right oh I was a graduate
student in the university of michigan
herbarium so i'm glad you got to know it
so if endowments aren't the answer which
I was beginning to think that they were
the periodic scrambling for money seems
to be the other alternative or is there
another one so i would i would do
something in between the question was if
endowments aren't the answer and
periodic scrambling for money isn't the
answer either and we all know how much
fun periodic screaming for money is so
i'm an in-betweener i want to i want to
endow things so that they will go for 20
years or 30 years and we know when we're
going to run out of this this lump so we
raise money for the thing and it acts
like endowment it throws off interest it
just isn't we shouldn't limit ourselves
i think to only doing the set of things
that will be supported with the
endowment we should spend it more fast
more rapidly than that believing that we
will generate things that are a value
and that value shows up in grants in
various other kinds of activities so
that we can expand the enterprise there
may be some things that are so so
important so valuable so so so unique it
can't be English that you that you
really do want to endow them so that you
can hold them for as long as the
monetary system you've endowed them in
holds together this is working out well
in Greece isn't it so but most things
most things that I think academics and
scholars and cultural heritage
institutions do we should be more
ambitious than settling for the rate of
return on down an endowment as being the
set of activities that we can support
but we shouldn't be at the mercy of an
annual budget cycle that's also not the
not the right place to be and I think
there actually is a substantial in
between
hi okay I was wondering if you could
speak to the interaction of analog
reservations or departments and digital
preservation because I would argue that
sometimes it's not so easy as sticking a
dead bird in a drawer and there are
lifecycle models and analog preservation
that I think the collaboration is not
always happening between preservation
and administration and digital
preservation so it's not always as easy
as putting the burden enjoy that was a
bad example I apologize and it's
certainly not as always as easy as
putting a book on a shelf which is the
world that I come from it would be very
useful if the if the physical preservers
and the digital preservers spent more
time talking about their common
interests because this this notion of
the life cycle isn't especially digital
actually it applies to all sorts of
things there are important technical
differences the things that there are
things that can go wrong with digital
that can't go wrong with analog there
are things that go wrong with digital
easily like it gets separated from its
own metadata that can go wrong with
analog but but it happens less often and
for because we have a physical thing
which which makes it makes it easier in
at the University of Michigan we have a
digital preservation librarian now
living in the conservation and
preservation unit and it's okay they
talk to each other they know they're in
the same business and I'm hoping to get
more more more out of that there's
another place where you can get a better
match which is which is for many
physical objects the 3d scanning and
printing actually becomes a form of
preservation it's not complete your
Europe you're obviously not preserving
the original there except by making it
less needed for lots of purposes so I
think this is a place where what you
want to do is get people together who
Bothan think they're in the preservation
business think they're there for
ultimately in the access business and
who are not snooty about their on the
value of their own work relative to the
others in fact
a longtime university administrator if
you can remove some of the sense of
snootiness that we each have about our
own particular areas things get a whole
lot better it's one more and then we've
really probably are out of time but I
feel very good about having gotten
questions thank you for the amusing talk
my question is are we prepared for a
change in technology and if so when do
you foresee that it's going to occur so
the question was are we prepared for
change in technology and the answer is
well absolutely and of course not so so
we we ought to be I mean so technology
is changing rapidly the things that you
can do and this is the demand side again
changes rapidly and as the next
generations of scholars and for that
matter museum goers and library users
see in their ordinary daily lives cool
stuff that they can do in other parts of
the world they will insist that they be
able to do those cool things in our
parts of the world to and and if we
don't deliver they're actually going to
not support us well so again my argument
that we need to have ongoing demand for
the kinds of activities realize demand
for the kind of activities we do in
order for them to to prosper I think is
right and so we'd better be open to
responding to those technical changes
with the built-in conservatism that
comes with the with the Academy so we
shouldn't be jumping to the to the fat
of the hour I'm actually rather hopeful
about that mostly except that I think
there are these cases have dropped
stitches lies in the digital world where
you can simply lose access to stuff you
thought you had access to because you
actually didn't own it but again going
back to the kinds of things Dominic was
talking about there's real technical
change deep technical change underneath
that set of activities that will in turn
change the way we do our work which will
in turn change the way that we collect
and preserve and openness to that and
and not thinking that that is a threat
to cool old things whether or not
they're into
roars I think is an important piece of
getting it done right thank you
okay just a couple of I just wanted to
end the plenary session by saying that I
think that Paul summed it up perfectly
when he said we're all in the access
business and they you know our three
speakers spend a lot of time talking
about enormous cultural technical
economic and policy challenges that
we've all been working with but i think
that the other side of these talks has
been that we were at this
extraordinarily exciting and much waited
for moment in time in which the the
fruits of our our work are beginning to
show and new ways of doing humanities
and science research and in fact opening
up the content to a broader community
even beyond the academy and that is why
we're managing the life cycle in the
first place so please join me in
thanking our plenary speakers one more
time and enjoy your lunch